bonjour à tous nous allons commencer
comme chaque semaine par le point presse
mercredi à 8h30 a lieu la deuxième
journée de travail donc celle ci sera
consacré au code du travail
elle et elle est à l'initiative d'eric
woerth isabelle le callennec et gérard
cherpion
cette journée sera suivie à 17 heures de
la commission exécutive
samedi 3 octobre nicolas sarkozy sera à
la fête départementale des républicains
de la loire et fera un discours en fin
de matinée donc dorénavant nicolas
sarkozy fera des meetings pour soutenir
tous les candidats aux régionales à peu
près 1 par semaine et il est 100%
mobilisée dans la perspective des
régionales est derrière nos candidats
le magazine des républicains donc est
paru aujourd'hui donc la une est dédié
aux régionales puisque c'est notre
priorité
plusieurs sujets sont traités dans dans
le magazine des sujets qui concernent
directement les français comme le
chômage puisque nous avons eu à les
derniers chiffres du chômage
encore un échec a encore une une
augmentation du chômage + 20 milles au
mois d'août l'immigration avec la
journée de travail qui a eu lieu sur eux
sur ce thème qui est véritablement très
important pour les français et puis la
crise agricole
avec différentes différentes
propositions
voilà donc le mouvement le parti est
dans l'unité et le rassemblement
et c'est ce que nous voyons à travers ce
magazine ou plusieurs ténors s'exprime
bonjour à tous donc quelques mots sur la
journée de mercredi une journée de
travail sur la réforme du code de
travail
mais au delà de la réforme du travail du
code du travail
la question qui se pose c'est comment
redonner de la confiance à nos
entreprises à nos entrepreneurs en
créant une vraie relation de confiance
et non pas de deuil de défiance comme
c'est trop souvent le cas aujourd'hui
entre les entreprises et
l'administration
et puis il sera question de de
l'entreprise comment la développer
comment lui permettre de conquérir des
marchés puisque les entreprises ce sont
elles qui créent la richesse et si on
veut qu'il ya un partage de la richesse
dans nos pays faut d'abord qu'on ait des
entreprises performantes qui puisse la
craie la question sera posée aussi de ce
que nous voulons faire des 35 heures on
a vu qu au gouvernement il y avait des
polémiques sans arrêt entre les
différents ministres ils ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux nous abordons ce
sujet j'allais dire de plein fouet de
plein fouet
et puis bien évidemment les entreprises
ce sont elles qui créent des emplois
malheureusement le gouvernement
aujourd'hui reste dans la création
d'emplois publics
malheureusement ce n'est pas par là que
nous allons sortir du chômage c'est
véritablement les entreprises qui nous
permettent de créer des emplois
puisqu'on parle du chômage on s'aperçut
ce mois ci encore que nous avons battu
un nouveau record en matière de chômage
malgré j'allais dire les les changements
de méthode de calcul qui était fait
subrepticement cet été pour essayer de
l'imiter
l'affichage de l'augmentation du chômage
est bien malgré cette entourloupe par le
gouvernement le chômage continue à
battre des records
la seule solution qui est trouvé
d'ailleurs le gouvernement c'est de
commander des rapports et lorsque ces
rapports lui sont remis et bien tout de
suite site une levée de boucliers pour
dire nous ne nous attaquons pas à un
certain nombre de totem le 30 les 35
heures
et finalement les règles du code du
travail et donc on s'aperçoit que le
gouvernement est très en retrait et
n'est pas du tout à l'offensive
alors qu'elles doivent ils devraient
l'être en matière de les réformes du
code du travail
nous nous sommes aperçus finalement que
sur 38 mois et bien eu seulement quatre
fois nous avions assisté à une légère
baisse du chômage sur 38 watts
donc ça veut dire 34 mois de hausse du
chômage
depuis que françois hollande est
président la république
et puis comme s'y était engagé et
nicolas sarkozy comme il le réaffirme
dans le magazine des rythmes des
républicains et bien il y aura à l'issue
de cette journée de travail
un questionnaire les adhérents des
républicains devront se prononcer sur
les positions sur le projet en matière
de réforme du code du travail que nous
proposerons français et ce questionnaire
d'une dizaine de questions et bien sera
envoyé au préalable donc dans la journée
de mardi à l'ensemble des membres du
bureau politique
c'est
la volonté de transparence de nicolas
sarkozy alors comme le comme le dit
sébastien en effet à des changements de
ministres mais en tout cas il n'y a pas
de changement de tendance pour le
chômage
il augmente il augmente et il augmente
de manière inexorable
nous allons passer au sujet des frappes
en syrie donc nous prenons acte des
premiers bombardements
toutefois cette cette initiative ne
masque pas le manque de leadership de la
france et de l'europe dans dans cette
crise syrienne
la france est marginalisé sur le plan
diplomatique on voit bien que la réunion
de barack obama et vladimir poutine est
bien françois hollande ne participe pas
donc son hyper finalement son manque de
leadership son manque d'initiative et la
france se trouve marginalisé
rappelons quand même que nicolas sarkozy
a été dès l'été 2012
celui qui a demandé le départ de bachar
el-assad bachar el-assad s'est quand
même deux cent mille morts sur la
conscience
donc nous considérons que bachar
el-assad ne peut pas être l'avenir de la
série néanmoins il faudra parler avec
avec des éléments du régime pour pouvoir
mettre en place cette transition
démocratique et cette transition
politique
autre point la rue cyr et devra être un
allié
ce qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de solution
possible sans la russie
voilà pour ce que nous pouvons dire de
sept de ses premières frappes en syrie
et puis et puis nous restons quand même
nous pensons qu'il faut quand même des
des frappes au sol dans le cadre d'une
coalition internationale avec des
troupes qui soit celle d'une coalition
dont les pays arabes de la région
prendrait plein pleinement part à 7 à
cette coalition